John is with us John's in Atlanta hi
John how are you hey Dave merry
Christmas to you Merry Christmas to you
what's up Dave I think I'm finally mad
in tired of the financial pain that I've
experienced over the past few years my
wife and I we've been married about 14
years five children got a good amount of
debt that we're trying to tackle I might
be a little too far out ahead of my wife
we had our first budget meeting last
night and uh started it with prayer and
in the middle of it it kind of blew off
the the good thing is it ended well and
I was just calling to see you know I'm
Dave I'm I'm serious I know God has a
better plan for my marriage and our
finances you know I it's a you know I
just started list I've actually listened
to you over the years and and didn't
like what you had to say and I like what
you have to say me I think my ears are
finely tuned in the right direction so
okay um what was the fight about
well it's you know we've never been
intentional with our money and you know
I've been I've got a friend that's uh
he's a lot younger than me but has the
wisdom the financial wisdom of any any
wise man that I've known and and I told
her that we needed to be more
intentional about our money and you know
she's talking about buying socks for the
children and I'm like honey where was
planned to buy socks for the children
it's not like we can't but let's talk
about it and and so that was kind of we
haven't learned how to talk about it
before yeah no I mean we've been made
for what I consider a good amount of
time and we're definitely stronger in
our marriage today than we were you know
13 years ago well what I would tell you
this is is this in Budget Committee
meeting discussions um since you're the
one initiating this you're the one
bringing she's coming to the table as a
favor to you lose some battles to win
the war the war
the whole family on a plan don't ever
fight over socks again right lose that
battle okay and she says we need get
socks for the kids absolutely when you
get socks for the kids which which
category would you like to put that in
honey right a hundred percent even if
you don't think the kids need socks I
mean whatever the thing is right
obviously if they do but I mean you know
what I'm saying you just lose it yeah
you just agree with her yeah now where
you want to put that which which county
you obviously about probably clothing
huh what do you want to is there enough
in the clothing on but enough in this
clothing category that we put down here
honey for you to get that are you okay
or do we need to put some more in there
and just lose that battle all right well
it did in her ID I showed her that every
dollar app and she says well why don't
we create a whole category for me and so
we've got you know wife Ashley and you
know no no all right no because she's
just talking when she said me she meant
the household and the kids because she
wants to protect them and herself from
you
she thinks you're getting ready to take
over you're the new communist tree in
the house yeah and the new communist
regime must be controlled and so let's
just put enough over here so I can
survive until he gets over this fad
that's what she was saying
so now hey let's do this what if with
the two of you go through Financial
Peace University if I gave it to you for
Christmas the nine week class one night
a week for nine weeks wave we would love
to why don't y'all go that that will
help both of you learn to talk about
this and but now we don't we don't need
a her category where most everything is
under her like the important stuff like
food and kids and that kind of stuff and
then over here you get to play try to
get out of debt on the other side now we
both need to be in agreement on the
thing top to bottom but lose some
battles to win the overall war hold on
I'll get you I'll get Kelly to pick up
we'll get you signed up for Financial
Peace University you guys are in the
right place now you've had you had an
initial discussion and you're disgusted
and ready to go and this is perfect
timing
it's the first of the year coming up and
it's a great time to start something
fresh and something new and this class
will rock your world change your
marriage give you all a way to talk
about the
and you won't have to be the bad guy you
know you'll learn how to pull into the
process rather than pushing of the
process and pullings just a lot more
effective so hold on we'll have Kelly
pick up we'll get you going on it too
it's honor to talk to you and thank you
for calling it merry Christmas to you
this is the Dave Ramsey show hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show
[Music]
you